[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Sievers guten
Abend Tina allen es bleibt dabei das
Sommermärchen 2006 war die beste WM
aller Zeiten so sagen das heute die
Anwälte eines ehemaligen
spitzenfunktionärs des deutschen
fußballbunds er und zwar seiner Kollegen
müssen nicht mehr mit einem Prozess in
Deutschland rechnen nach jahrelangen
Ermittlungen hat das Gericht das
Verfahren eingestellt es ging um
mysteriöse Geldflüsse in Zusammenhang
mit der WM in Deutschland
dutzende Ermittlungsverfahren massive
Korruptionsvorwürfe gibt es wegen der
Vergabe der WM an Katha und dennoch
beginnt diese WM in drei Wochen in Katar
das Emirat hat Stadien gebaut denen eine
Zukunft als Investment Ruinen
bevorstehen dürfte viele tausend
Arbeiter sind auf den Baustellen
gestorben und die Fans weltweit stehen
jetzt vor einem unangenehmen Dilemma
kann man das ganze abstoßend und absurd
finden und gleichzeitig aus vollem
Herzen jubeln der deutsche
fußballpräsident und die
bundesinnenministerin wollen sich vor
Ort ein Bild machen Jutta sonnewald
ihr Besuch in Katar knapp drei Wochen
vor Beginn der Fußball-WM stand schon
auf der Kippe
bundesinnenministerin Nancy Feser hatte
im Vorfeld dieser Reise mit ihrer Kritik
am WM Gastgeberland die Gemüter der
katarischen Regierung verstimmt dennoch
ist Nancy Feser heute mit dem
DFB-Präsidenten an den Persischen Golf
gereist dennoch wurde offen auch mit
Betroffenen über Menschenrechte
Diskriminierung und Verfolgung
diskutiert das waren sehr interessanter
guter Austausch es wurde hervorgehoben
dass sehr gute Gesetze auf den Weg
gebracht wurden in den letzten Jahren
und das ist jetzt darum ginge diese
natürlich auch mit Leben zu füllen
schätzungsweise 30.000 Arbeitsmigranten
vor allem aus Südasien haben in den
letzten Jahren im Wüstenstaat 8
hochmoderne Stadien erbaut prunkvolle
Luxushotels fünfspurige Straßen und eine
nagelneue Metro dabei Hausen sie oft
unter erbärmlichen Umständen 60 Stunden
Wochen bei Temperaturen um 50 Grad im
Sommer monatelang keinen Lohn
Arbeitsverträge die sie wie Leibeigene
binden ein gnadenlos ausbeuterisches
System das in den letzten zehn Jahren
mehr als 6.500 Todesopfer gefordert
haben soll
it to be Infarkt würde nicht helfen im
Gegenteil es würde den Arbeitsmigranten
schaden sie müssten es am Ende ausbaden
die Regierung und die Behörden würden
sie dafür büßen lassen sie würden sagen
wir haben wegen euch bei der WM Verluste
gemacht daher werden wir arbeitsreformen
wieder rückgängig machen also bitte
nicht boykottieren
Menschenrechtsorganisationen wie Amnesty
International fordern stattdessen vom
Weltfußballverband FIFA einen
Entschädigungsfond für Arbeitsmigranten
in Höhe von mindestens 440 Millionen
US-Dollar einzurichten sie hoffen dass
der Golfstaat nach der WM seine
begonnenen Reformen fortsetzt das sind
Forderungen die über den Tag hinaus
denken die bleiben würden und das
eigentlich auch Katar schon über die WM
2022 hinausschaut und sich Katar
durchaus auch bewusst ist dass sie
weiter ArbeitsmigrantInnen brauchen
werden und dass sie auch gewisse
Standards einhalten müssen der frühere
Außenminister und SPD-Politiker sig
gabriel ist schon 40 über die seiner
Meinung nach arrogante deutsche
Diskussion rund um das WM Gastgeberland
statt die Reformen des golfstaates zu
loben würden die Deutschen das Emiraten
nur beleidigen Fortschritt kommt nicht
über Nacht sondern Schritt für Schritt
twittert Gabriel wie heikel der Umgang
mit der umstrittenen Fußball-WM ist
zeigt sich auch am Dilemma vieler
Veranstalter wie Hans-Georg Stocker der
Chef der Münchner Konzertlocation
Backstage hat lange gerungen ob er die
Spiele hier öffentlich zeigen soll oder
nicht
wir werden es zeigen zumindest die
Deutschlandspiele unter der Bedingung
dass immer eine kritische Begleitung
läuft also das heißt wir wollen sicher
Dokumentationen zeigen das sind noch
dran Veranstaltungen zu machen wo wir
die Leute vom public view über die
Situation informieren Hans-Georg Stocker
will zudem etwas von den
getränkeeinnahmen beim Public Viewing
abzwacken und dem Entschädigungsfond
beisteuern der von Menschenrechtlern und
vom DFB schon lange gefordert aber von
der FIFA bisher immer noch nicht
eingerichtet wurde
und direkt aus Doha jetzt bei uns in der
Sendung der Präsident des Deutschen
Fußballbundes Bernd Neuendorf Herr
Neuendorf guten Abend
hallo hier ja Katha scheint zunehmend
nervös und verärgert der Emir sieht sein
Land einer beispiellosen Kampagne
ausgesetzt ich nehme an das haben die
Gastgeber ihnen gegenüber auch beklagt
was haben Sie denn geantwortet
wir sind ja heute erst angekommen in
Doha und die politischen Gespräche der
Ministerin muss man sagen die finden
dann hauptsächlich morgen statt wir
haben uns heute getroffen mit
Vertreterinnen und Vertretern von
Arbeitnehmerorganisationen haben uns
angehört welche Veränderungen es hier
gegeben hat im Land zum Positiven aber
wo es auch noch Herausforderungen gibt
und ich habe meinerseits und für den DFB
meine Forderungen auch wiederholt dass
wir hier glauben dass wir sogenannte
Migration working Centers brauchen in
Doha weil wir arbeiten Menschen aus
vielen vielen Nationen und wir sind der
Meinung sie müssen die Möglichkeit haben
ihre Interessen an einer Stelle auch
vorzutragen rechtlichen Beistand zu
bekommen
Informationen zu erhalten das ist für
mich ganz wesentlich
können Sie den deutschen Fans guten
Gewissens empfehlen nach Katar zu fahren
es ist so dass am Ende des Tages jeder
das für sich selber entscheiden muss wir
haben jüngste Zahlen der FIFA die sagen
dass
35.000 kartenbestellungen der von nach
Deutschland gegangen sind sodass wir
davon ausgehen können dass wir hier
deutsche Fans erleben werden wir sind
darauf gut vorbereitet als DFB eine der
wenigen Nationen die hier auch Fan
Einrichtungen und Fan Anlaufpunkte Fan
Botschaften errichten wird wo wir rund
um die WM für alle Fragen zur Verfügung
stehen sollte es Probleme geben wir
stehen damit Rad und Rat und Tat zur
Seite
ansonsten glaube ich muss jeder selber
entscheiden ob er dieses Turnier
entweder in Doha direkt oder auch vor
dem Fernseher verfolgt da möchte ich
eigentlich überhaupt keine Ratschläge
geben jetzt ist es ja so dass auch
Nationalspieler wie jetzt gerade bei uns
hier im Sportstudio Nico schotterbeck
von Borussia Dortmund sagen dass die WM
nicht nach Katar gehört das wissen wir
alle dass die WM nicht in den Winter
gehört das wissen wir alle auch dennoch
die WM findet ja statt auch im Winter
und eben in Katar wie ist es bei ihnen
fürchten sie am Ende dass Kata sagt was
habt ihr denn alle ist doch toll
gelaufen oder wird das am Ende ein
abschreckendes Beispiel sein für die
Zukunft
wir haben ja auch sehr frühzeitig gesagt
dass wir bei der Vergabe von solchen
großen Turnieren
Fußball-Weltmeisterschaften insbesondere
sehr stark darauf achten müssen wie sind
eigentlich die Vergabekriterien und das
spielt das Thema Nachhaltigkeit der
spielt das Thema Menschenrechte
sicherlich eine Rolle und das kann man
sicherlich heute schon sagen dass die
Vergabe des Turniers nach Katar und der
Prozess der danach eingesetzt hat den
Sport schon sehr verändert hat er sehr
viel politischer geworden und wir werden
glaube ich eine Vergabe die ohne
ja ohne Berücksichtigung solcher Themen
wie Nachhaltigkeit und Menschenrechte
glaube ich nicht mehr erleben man muss
im Vorfeld über diese Dinge diskutieren
das werden wir nicht mehr erleben sind
sie sich da ganz sicher denn wir haben
ja gerade gemerkt auch am Beispiel Katar
ganz intensiv das für die FIFA vor allem
ein Argument zählt nämlich Geld
verdienen warum sollte sich das ändern
die FIFA hat ja schon reagiert sie hat
das Thema Menschenrechte jetzt schon
aufgenommen in den Kriterienkatalog für
die Vergabe solcher Weltmeisterschaften
und das ist eine Reaktion und noch mal
wir haben überall im Land in Deutschland
aber auch darüber hinaus Diskussionen
über diese Vergabe deshalb glaube ich
auch dass es im Interesse der FIFA und
von fußballorganisationen sein muss auch
eine gesellschaftliche Akzeptanz zu
gewinnen für die Vergabe solcher
Turniere und dafür stehe ich auch
plötzlich ist es ein Dilemma etwas ist
ein Dilemma geworden das doch eigentlich
nur schön sein sollte und ohne dass man
über das man eigentlich nicht mehr groß
nachdenken sollte wie sehen Sie das
jetzt sollte man sich freuen auf so eine
WM sollte man sich das antun was sagen
sie denn Fans
ich habe es ja eben schon gesagt das
muss jeder entscheiden ob er herkommt
und wir mit der WM umgeht ich glaube
schon dass der Fußball an sich immer
eine gewisse Faszination ausübt wir
haben die Paarungen jetzt in der
Vorrunde und ich gehe fest davon aus
dass wir uns qualifizieren für die k.o
Runde und dann kommen spannende Spieler
auf uns zu die Begeisterung für den
Fußball ist glaube ich bekannt in
Deutschland auch darüber hinaus aber ich
bin ziemlich sicher dass viele Menschen
das Turnier auch verfolgen werden aber
natürlich wird es auch Menschen geben
die sagen ich möchte lieber nicht
zuschauen und was ist wenn Spieler jetzt
sagen dass es eh irgendwie ein blödes
Turnier da ist es eigentlich auch egal
wie wir spielen wie wir abschneiden
in dieser Form habe ich jetzt noch
keinen Spieler gehört dass er sich
geäußert hat wir haben ja folgendes
gemacht die Spielerinnen und die Spieler
insbesondere jetzt hier wir haben sie
vor dem WM-Turnier zusammengeholt wir
haben sie mit
Menschenrechtsorganisationen diskutieren
lassen wir haben aufgeklärt über die
Situation hier im Land jeder konnte sich
ein Bild machen von der Lage hier und
ich glaube das ist erstmal wichtig dass
wir auch einen menschenrechtskongress
durchgeführt haben beim DFB wohl
Nationalspieler teilgenommen haben also
wir haben uns schon sehr viel Mühe
gegeben die Spieler einzubinden zu
informieren und sind mündige Spieler und
starke Charaktere und die sozusagen
bilden sich dann auch ihre Meinung und
das ist auch in Ordnung aus Kata wo er
gerade ist auf Inspektionsreise
sozusagen der Präsident des Deutschen
Fußball-Bundes Bernd Neuendorf
herzlichen Dank
danke auch vielen Dank
und das Gespräch haben was technischen
Gründen kurz vor der Sendung
aufgezeichnet die WM in einem Winter der
ohnehin anders werden dürfte als die
davor ein Winter 2022 bei dem sich
Menschen im reichsten Industrieland
Europas Sorgen machen ob das Geld reicht
um die Wohnung zu heizen die
Bundesregierung will diese Sorgen
mindern entscheidend dabei soll sein was
eine Kommission erarbeitet die hat heute
ihren Abschlussbericht vorgelegt wenn
der so umgesetzt wird könnte laut
Verbraucherzentralen ein größerer
vierpersonen-haushalt mit rund 1.000
Euro im Jahr an Hilfe rechnen Details
hat Frank Buchwald
der Kanzler strahlt etwas angestrengt
aber sieht das schon aus die Sache ist
ja auch ernst die Gaspreise explodieren
und Berlin will Bremsen noch in dieser
Woche werden wir Eckpunkte vorstellen
wie die Vorschläge der gastkommission
umgesetzt werden können genauso wie die
strompreisbremse das gaspreisbremse und
strompreisbremse schnell umgesetzt
werden können
wochenlang hatte eine Expertenkommission
beraten am Vormittag hat sie brav ihren
Bericht abgeliefert damit ist nun ganz
offiziell was eigentlich seit langem
bekannt ist die gaspreisbremse so
schlagen die Experten vor soll schon im
Dezember wirken
Privathaushalte bekommen für diesen
Monat ihre Abschlagszahlung ersetzt
spätestens aber mit der nächsten
Nebenkostenabrechnung im März soll dann
eine Begrenzung der Gaspreise kommen für
die Industrie bereits im Januar das
Papier liegt danach auf dem Tisch der
konzertierten Aktion im Kanzleramt vor
allem die Gewerkschaften hatten
kritisiert die Hilfen sein sozial
unausgewogen diese Sorge aber scheint
nun ausgeräumt es gibt ein weiteres
gerechtigkeitssignal das ist nämlich
dass uns heute auch noch mal der
Bundesfinanzminister klar gesagt hat
dass die Abschlagsrechnungen die
übernommen werden ab einer einem
Einkommen von 75.000 Euro im kommenden
Jahr zu versteuern ist die exakte
Einkommensgrenze kennt zwar noch niemand
ganz genau das berüchtigte
gießkannenprinz jedoch einer der
zentralen Kritikpunkte am Konzept der
Kommission ist weg auch für die
Wirtschaft Firmen die Hilfe beantragen
müssen Standorte und Arbeitsplätze
erhalten dafür gilt die Regelung nun
auch für kleine und mittlere Unternehmen
wir brauchen dringend Entlastungen für
die Unternehmen damit sie weiter
produzieren können die gestiegenen
Preise können von den Unternehmen nicht
einfach in den Markt weitergegeben
werden Scholz hat sein Konzept breit
abgestützt nicht nur die Tarifpartner
haben mit beraten auch sozial und
Verbraucherverbände der Mieterbund und
viele andere die Opposition jedoch nicht
überzeugt die preisbremsen kommen zu
spät für diesen Winter die sollen im
März oder April kommen aber niemand
sieht sein Winterreifen im März oder
April auf den bräuchten wir für diesen
Winter was allerdings im Gesetz stehen
wird wer genau wie viel bekommt und vor
allem wann das entscheidet jetzt erstmal
die Bundesregierung noch in dieser Woche
sagt der Kanzler und will Zuversicht
ausstrahlen
Mittwoch bereit dann das Kabinett
so jetzt Nachrichten in der Übersicht
und die hast du Hannah eine engere
Zusammenarbeit vor allem im
Energiesektor das war eines der Ziele
von bundesaußenministerin baerborg bei
ihrem Besuch in Kasachstan etwa beim
grünen Wasserstoff dafür wolle
Deutschland gemeinsam mit der EU in die
Infrastruktur des Landes investieren
erklärte bärbock am Nachmittag reiste
sie dann weiter nach Usbekistan beide
exorbiert Republiken haben traditionell
enge Beziehungen zu Russland und China
gut drei Wochen nach der Landtagswahl in
Niedersachsen haben SPD und Grüne ihre
Koalitionsverhandlungen erfolgreich
abgeschlossen beide Parteien kündigten
an dass sie morgen den gemeinsamen
Koalitionsvertrag vorstellen wollen am
Wochenende soll dann bei
Landesparteitagen von SPD und Grünen
darüber abgestimmt werden
Ministerpräsident weil regierte bereits
in seiner ersten Amtszeit in einer
Koalition mit den Grünen dann folgte ein
Bündnis mit der CDU
nach der Veröffentlichung von geheimen
nsu-akten durch das ZDF-Magazin Royale
und die Plattform fragt den Staat hat
das hessische Landesamt für
Verfassungsschutz Strafanzeige gegen
Unbekannt gestellt dabei geht es nicht
um die Veröffentlichung der Dokumente
sondern um die unrechtmäßige Weitergabe
der NSU hatte neun Menschen türkischer
und griechischer Herkunft und eine
Polizistin ermordet die veröffentlichten
Akten zeigten nun dass die Ermittler
wichtigen Hinweisen nicht nachgingen
einen Tag nach dem Einsturz einer
Hängebrücke in der westindischen Stadt
morby ist die Zahl der Toten auf
mindestens 134 gestiegen noch immer
suchen Rettungskräfte nach Vermissten
laut Behörden befanden sich gestern
hunderte Menschen auf der Brücke als die
tragekabelrissen 9 mutmaßlich für den
Einsturz verantwortliche Personen wurden
heute festgenommen darunter auch Manager
der Firma die die historische Brücke in
den vergangenen Monaten saniert hatten
obwohl Russland am Samstag das
getreideabkommen mit der Ukraine
ausgesetzt hat wurden die Exporte heute
fortgesetzt laut den Vereinten Nationen
und der ukrainischen Regierung verließen
zwölf rachter die schwarzmeerhäfen des
Landes der Kreml bezeichnete dies als
riskant der türkische Präsident Erdogan
kündigte an sich für eine Fortsetzung
des Abkommens einzusetzen
Kiew die verwunschen schöne Hauptstadt
eines Landes im Krieg lebte diesen
Sommer in der Hoffnung das Schlimmste
könnte ihr erspart geblieben sein der
Kampf gegen die russischen Angreifer
tobte im Osten die ukrainische Armee
eroberte Kilometer um Kilometer zurück
und die Menschen in Kiew hatten sich ihr
Leben zurückerobert das ist vorbei heute
wie an jedem Montag der vergangenen
Woche meldet die Luftabwehr der Ukraine
wieder massive Raketenangriffe und in
Kiew fehlt nicht nur der Strom sondern
auch das Wasser betroffen sind laut
Bürgermeister 80 Prozent der drei
Millionen Einwohner Vitali Klitschko
sagt seinen Bürgerinnen und Bürgern sie
sollen sich an öffentlichen Brunnen mit
Trinkwasser eindecken
im Gebiet rund um die Hauptstadt werden
die Menschen gewarnt sie müssten sich
für lange Stromausfälle wappnen unser
Korrespondent daran ist in Odessa hallo
Dara die menschenverachtende Taktik der
Angreifer scheint also klar wie wollen
wir die ukrainischen Städte so über
einen kalten Winter kommen
er zum einen stellen sich die Menschen
sonntags schon darauf ein dass sie sie
am Montag getroffen werden können vor
allem im Berufsverkehr werden diese
massiven Luftangriffe geflogen hier in
Odessa hatte man heute den ganzen Tag
und auch gestern schon große Sorgen weil
ja das getreideabkommen von Russland
aufgelöst wurde getroffen wurde
allerdings Kiew hunderttausende waren
heute vom Wasser abgeschnitten einer
davon war Dima den hatte ich angerufen
weil er gerade aus dem Krankenhaus
entlassen wurde er hatte eine
Blinddarm-OP hinter sich und er sagte
mir hat noch drei Liter Wasser also er
braucht schnell
wieder Zugang zum Wasser und so geht es
natürlich vielen Menschen dort im Moment
haben wir einen warmen Oktober aber
jeder weiß hier dass der kalte Winter
kommen wird und die Infrastruktur sie
ist wirklich am Boden
du bleibst noch ein Moment bei uns bitte
denn währenddessen gehen an der Front im
Südosten die Kämpfe weiter die Region
wohin daran Hassan uns jetzt mitnimmt
die sei so werfen die Ukraine das
Russland vor eine Zone ohne Zivilisation
geworden
wir fahren zur Front forcherson die 59
Brigade steht wenige Kilometer vor der
Stadt seit Wochen warum erklärt uns sehr
Kapitän der mehr als 3000 Mann starken
Einheit
militärtechnisch hätten wir Version
schon vor zwei Monaten einnehmen können
aber viele unserer Soldaten wären
gefallen
strategische jedoch im Hinblick auf die
Verteidigung des ganzen Landes vom
Norden bis Süden hat unser Oberkommando
entschieden dass dies zu früh gewesen
wäre
wir sind beim artilleriezug der Brigade
stationiert den Fronten her warten auf
den Einsatz Befehl der aber jeden Moment
kommen kann das ist die Alltag seit
Wochen die Gegenoffensive auf Herz und
könnte schneller verlaufen für Ihren
Geschmack
sicherlich geht es nicht so schnell wie
wir es uns wünschen aber wir geben alles
wir kämpfen um unsere Dörfer und Städte
zu befreien will ich dass es schneller
geht ja das will ich
die Munition wird ungeschützt dem LKW
gelagert direkt daneben unter der Decke
schläft ein Soldat
zu erholen wir uns wie du siehst
ihre Artillerie ist eine D 20 aus den
70er Jahren eine sowjetproduktion
zuverlässig aber Schwächen in Reichweite
und Präzision moderne westliche
Artillerie steht dieser Einheit nicht
zur Verfügung
guten Morgen
offensiven aus das heißt Artillerie
beschießt Artillerie es ist eine Art
Jagd auf Artilleriestellung wir sind
meistens in den Feldern unterwegs und im
Angriffe und Gegenangriffe verwickelt
ein Katz und Mausspiel ein tödliches der
Erfolg der gegen Offensive das Leben der
Soldaten jetzt hängt es von zwei
Faktoren ab Geschwindigkeit und
Präzision die Stadt herson ist nur 10 km
von hier entfernt die russischen Linien
gar weniger
nach Abschluss bleiben zwei Minuten dann
könnte der Feind die Stellung
lokalisiert haben und zurückschießen
sie werden noch Sex weitere Salven
Abfeuern von anderen Positionen am Ende
des Einsatzes sei ein russischer Panzer
getroffen worden sagt das ukrainische
Militär
aus Schutz vor feindlicher Artillerie
wurden hunderte solcher Gräben vorher
schon angelegt per Hand ausgehoben so
wird selbst ein Krieg der Artillerie von
Stiefeln und Spaten getragen vor allem
wenn der Winter näher rückt
unser nächstes Thema
50,9 zu 49,1 so sieht ein gespaltenes
Land in Zahlen aus es ist der hauchdünne
Vorsprung mit dem Luis enagio lullada
Silva vor der spektakulären Rückkehr in
ein Amt steht dass er bis Ende 2010
schon einmal hatte Präsident von 215
Millionen Menschen in Brasilien während
der Wahl Gewinner Glückwünsche aus aller
Welt entgegen nimmt bleiben im Land
selbst nach einem schmutzigen Wahlkampf
viele Fragen darunter diese hier warum
sagt der aktuelle Präsident nichts aus
Rio Christoph röckerath
die Fahrt seiner Autokolonne von der
Residenz zum Amtssitz in der Hauptstadt
Brasilia ist das bisher einzige
Lebenszeichen von Präsident bolzenaru
nach seiner Niederlage noch immer hat er
nicht gesagt ob er sie anerkennt sein
lautes Schweigen ruft nun seine
bisherigen Verbündeten im Parlament auf
den Plan die schaffen Fakten
auch Präsident das Abgeordnetenhaus
gratuliert dem gewählten Präsidenten
es ist dann der Zeit gegenseitig
abzurüsten wir müssen unseren Gegnern
die Hand reichen miteinander reden und
Brücken bauen
Flavio gibt sich per Twitter ungewohnt
kleinlaut kein Wort von einer Anfechtung
der Wahl danke an jeden einzelnen
schreibt er
und so könnte die Mischung aus Freude
und Erleichterung unter den Anhängern
Lulas die sich gestern in Rio Bahn
bricht als das Ergebnis verkündet wird
über den Moment hinaus Bestand haben
[Applaus]
das Volk wurde unterdrückt von so viel
Intoleranz Gewalt und dem
waffenkult-bold zu Narus aber jetzt ist
Lula dran
das Wahlergebnis ist äußerst knapp am
Ende trennen die beiden Kontrahenten
weniger als zwei Prozentpunkte Lula wird
mit seinem Amtsantritt ein tief
gespaltenes Land übernehmen und so
bemüht er sich auch an der Stunde des
Triumphes um versöhnliche Töne
ab dem ersten Januar 2023 werde ich für
alle 215 Millionen Brasilianer regieren
und nicht nur für die die mich gewählt
haben es gibt keine zwei Brasilien
für sie half alles beten nichts viele
Anhänger bolzenarus wollen die
Niederlage nicht wahrhaben
jule hat die Wahl nicht gewonnen diese
Wahl wurde gefälscht viele Unterstützer
bolzenarus denken ähnlich selbst wenn er
jetzt klein beigeben sollte der Schaden
für die Demokratie Brasiliens könnte
längst angerichtet sein
der bolzenarismus ist nicht tot
bolzenaru selbst der gestern besiegt
wurde erlebt natürlich gerade einen sehr
schlechten Moment aber als politischer
Führer ist er nicht erledigt es ist
möglich dass wir in drei bis vier Jahren
wieder eine Krise der Demokratie erleben
könnten
[Musik]
für heute aber heißt es aus dem Umfeld
des noch Präsidenten er würde sich
später äußern vielleicht erst morgen er
sei müde
zurück nach Deutschland die Lage in
deutschen Innenstädten ist hier alles
andere als rosig die Lage beim letzten
großen kaufhauskonzern in Deutschland
scheint auch alles andere als rosig zu
sein ganz genau Christian die
Warenhauskette Galeria Karstadt Kaufhof
kommt nicht raus aus der Krise und sucht
nun erneut Rettung in einem Schutzschirm
Insolvenzverfahren und das wird spürbare
Konsequenzen haben auch für die
Beschäftigten Frank Bethmann was ist da
genau zu erwarten insgesamt nichts Gutes
nicht zum ersten Mal muss das
Unternehmen unter einen solchen
Schutzschirm Zuflucht suchen bereits im
Frühjahr 2020 hat man versucht das
Traditionshaus auf diese Weise zu
sanieren damals schon wurden Standorte
geschlossen mussten tausende Mitarbeiter
gehen nun also geht die Rosskur weiter
mit schmerzhaften Auswirkungen wie
Konzernchef Müllenbach einräumen muss
das bestehende Filialen Netz muss zur
Umsetzung des Zukunftskonzepts deutlich
und mindestens ein Drittel reduziert
werden in den Filialen die wir nicht
weiter führen wird es betriebsbedingte
Kündigungen geben mit diesen
Ankündigungen droht über 40 der noch 131
bestehenden Warenhäusern das aus bei den
zurückliegenden Sanierungen hat der Bund
den Konzern insgesamt bereits mit 680
Millionen Euro gestützt zu weiteren
Hilfen war ja nun offenbar nicht mehr
bereit und das könnte auch mit ihm
Zusammenhängen René Benko
österreichischer Immobilieninvestor
seiner Signer Holding gehört Galeria
Karstadt Kaufhof zuletzt wurden seine
Büros von der Staatsanwaltschaft
durchsucht
Korruptionsverdacht die Razzia sicher
nicht hilfreich im Bemühen um weitere
Staatshilfen und so muss Galeria
Karstadt Kaufhof nun mehr denn je um
seine Existenz fürchten vielen Dank
Frank für deine Einschätzung
die Inflation im Euroraum hat im Oktober
einen neuen Rekord erreicht und zwar
10,7% im Vergleich zum Vorjahresmonat
grund dafür sind vor allem die
gestiegenen Energiekosten in den
baltischen Ländern ist die Inflation
dabei am höchsten Spitzenreiter Estland
verzeichnet mehr als 22%
dieser oktober hat mit sommerlichen
Temperaturen ja nicht geizt nun ist klar
er gehört zu den wärmsten seit
Aufzeichnungsbeginn die
Durchschnittstemperatur lag laut dem
Deutschen Wetterdienst bei 12,5 Grad was
dem Rekordwert aus dem Jahr 2001
entspricht und dieser könnte sogar noch
gebrochen werden denn die Bilanz ist
vorläufig der Deutsche Wetterdienst
sprach von einem Blick in unsere
Klimazukunft die oktober zwischen
1991 und 2020 waren im Schnitt 3,1 Grad
kühler als in diesem Jahr
china steht kurz vor der Fertigstellung
seiner eigenen Weltraumstationen am
Morgen startete in when Chang eine
Rakete mit dem dritten und letzten Modul
ins All das war vollständig die
t-förmiger Station Tiangong zu deutsch
himmelspalast auf der zurzeit drei
tycoon-nauten leben und arbeiten sollte
die Internationale Raumstation ISS in
den kommenden Jahren ihren Dienst
einstellen müssen wäre China dann die
einzige Nation mit einem ständig
bewohnten austenposten im All
und das war unser heute journal danke
und gerne bis morgen und unser heute
journal Update gibt es heute gegen
Mitternacht mit Wolf schmiese
[Musik]
guten Abend dieser Oktober war extrem
warm mehr als drei Grad wärmer als im
vierjährigen klimatologischen Mittel zu
erwarten gewesen wäre deutschlandweit
und die größten Abweichungen nach oben
gab es in Bayern in Baden-Württemberg
und auch im südlichen Rheinland-Pfalz so
warm so mild geht es aber nicht weiter
und das liegt an einigen Tiefs Kaarster
lief und Marion die Gestalten nämlich
das Wetter der nächsten Tage doch
deutlich wechselhafter mit Regen zum
Teil auch durchaus mit Sturm mit dem
Regen geht es schon heute Nacht im
Westen los im Osten ist es noch trocken
da bildet sich zum Teil auch noch mal
Nebel unter den Regenwolken sinken die
Temperaturen auf 15 bis 10 Grad hier in
Sachsen und in Bayern wird es mit 9 bis
6 Grad kühler und für einen ersten
November ist das morgen wieder ein sehr
milder Tag 14 Grad am Alpenrand 20 Grad
im südlichen Brandenburg oder in Sachsen
der Regen der Nacht sieht im Laufe des
Vormittags weiter ostwärts das wird für
die meisten von uns eher ein trüber
Vormittag das ändert sich am Nachmittag
dann regnet es noch am Alpenrand und
auch in Südostbayern sonst aber gibt es
viel Sonne am Mittwoch gibt es dann
Schauer und Gewitter in Norddeutschland
am Donnerstag kommt neuer Regen von
Westen heran und am Freitag wird es vor
allen Dingen an der See richtig
stürmisch weil nur noch sieben bis 14
Grad und wie sie hier am Wetter und
Temperatur Trend für Oberstdorf im
Allgäu sehen können könnte es am Samstag
tatsächlich für einige nasse
Schneeflocken reichen wenigstens
vorübergehend guten Abend